hello and welcome to this video playing
hon 413 oh wow I got seven out of seven
again step that's a lot okay let's see
what we what we get doing for my old go
go if I have won seven out of seven
against him I shouldn't do something
fancy just depend what I usually do ok
care for him I should have taken on d
phone I'm making mistakes in this
opening that I really shouldn't
shouldn't make I forgot to take on
default ok because I don't want to give
up the bishop pair here this particular
position ok anyway it's still not lost
or anything you're just not not what I
wanted you have to be ready to go d5
maybe you should just go ahead okay
interesting move yeah why does better
him no doubt maybe four point is more
it's on the weak side and I have some
some problems here with coordination
would like to move my d7 night but if I
do I'll lose a new stuff and Lucy for
okay at least at least the queenside
going to open up but the position is
really really bad the my only charges
that he plays f3 at some moment where is
not totally appropriate okay so now I'm
starting to run out of moves maybe maybe
I can play h4 h4 g 495
95 then night XD father's night XG form
which is not brilliant but at least
somewhat complicated I asked many good
options you can also just further
improve this position but maybe now okay
sometimes I might be able to take on
tape might be able to take on g4 okay so
yeah this is clear that's what happening
so again I can look at night takes the
at least briefly and i take c 4 is what
i wanted to do it i wonder if maybe
night takes g4 isn't that terrible this
is actually kind of interesting as I've
got h3 and it doesn't have such a very
easy reply to that yeah this move takes
Queen takes e4 should work Bishop f3 he
has to play the napkin Bishop f5 even
though Knight f6 check is coming that's
not good
that's not good huh I was thinking
bishop at five but it doesn't really
work Akron age who I can't even take 26
year
no good moose they have no good move
here absolutely not f5 is pretty bad but
I didn't see anything okay I should have
just taken you for and B and play this
verse position this is really not
working at all I can just play whatever
93-92 all wins that might win as well
but at least I see some ideas now Queen
a three
I it's still pretty harmless my bishop
on see hmm doesn't do anything I can
check here but doesn't really help much
and try to keep some some tension here
maybe i will get nervous it's not super
obvious how to convert this cannot move
the points easily but okay why should
win of course I'd like to get the rook
to f3 at least but don't don't see how
that would work
hmm
23 probably here I don't want to tread
queens am definitely not going back is
also not great
time warning yeah but I cannot trade
Queens it's just just too easy Green g5
is good now now it's just I mean okay i
know i just said i won't don't want to
trade queens but if I don't I'm just
getting shagged mated myself probably
does it have to trade you can go queen
to have seven what's doing now you
really spend that much time okay no big
choice
okay we'll change this and now is there
any any hope I need my bishop here and
take here maybe he's checkmating me but
okay if i get f to my position isn't
that doesn't clear having I've got three
points now for the piece check check 25
is almost made but ok let's go age two
check check check me yeah somehow I
don't know I seem to win against him
whatever I do I was pretty terrible I
mean I had started with my bed opening
yet forgot to take on d4 and this
happened to me before yeah as I should
definitely take on d4 and this pollution
I mean I don't have to but it's this is
the kind of position that I'd like I
want to play and I don't don't want this
one it's really not not fun that just
it's just not any good it just isn't any
good maybe here c5 also is this is
helping him yeah here this is just a bad
position the queenside got locked down
but now you're really out of ideas at
age 4 was i mean i can probably it's
best here to just
totally shuffle don't do anything and
ask him about his idea it's not so easy
for what to do to to get somewhere
because there's only f3 left to to open
the position and this is not this is
getting rid of my main weakness on e4
okay but I didn't want to sit and wait
and play to plate this which is probably
not good check ya hear this was what I
originally wanted to do but I felt like
okay yeah I'm just goes for forever like
this year and man just not good yeah
this is just not working at all I was
thinking Tom Bishop f5 but he just has
an idea of six check check and twins
here this is just a loss the only reason
why a black and continuous the somewhat
shaky White King position you can always
always hope but in just objectively
speaking a loss now here it started to
become more interesting even though
white so should win check Jan now what
can still cover here Bishop d3 is very
save actually the bishop is covering
this and nothing happens here he wins
with the deep on yeah yeah I really
should have won this game but check this
it was also wasn't particularly yeah
there's no reason to resign the position
was complicated enough to continue to
play ok thanks for watching